it's gonna look completely different
than any other street race you've seen
the cars are gonna go way back there
they're gonna be way more precise it's
it's a totally different ballgame here
reason why I don't like these desks here
is because of the cable management we
are setting out to do our most ambitious
anime video ever the working title of
the video is called anime a self-driving
car race Sam and Ren are heading up this
project it is their job right now to
figure out what goes into making
three-dimensional scenes that actually
contain cars racing how much we're able
to get out of these scenes will
determine how much we need to shoot
later on they're using new software and
it's a new effect that neither of them
have done and they only have a week
figure out how to do this Spencer has
just given us another secret gem of
knowledge here and that secret gem of
knowledge is that little iPhone app
called pix 4d picks 4d automates the
drone our drone our aerial
cinematography and racing ru AV the
flying camera in kind of like a
lawnmower pattern take pictures of a
landscape so it allows us to take the
images later and construct a 3d model
are you gonna try to do Hunter Street
I'm thinking so small scale I'm talking
the roof like I just want to make sure
the drone flies takes its picture as
follows the path but let the robots do
the work I was gonna have higher Ren the
fly had 200 take pictures but I've
decided to replace his job with a robot
do you know jobs are safe how did this
idea start the weirdest ideas come from
strangest places always we like to play
around with cool technology for videos
this is a few months ago when Tesla was
still just rolling out the auto pilot
programs and I was thinking how funny
would it be to do a street race in
autonomous cars
hop in the car and you hit a button and
it's like all the intensity of the Fast
and the Furious but you cut to inside
the cars and everyone's just like like
they're not doing anything you're
basically waiting until the race is over
you can't use real cars the video and
the idea just like real cars don't do
the things we need them to do not to
mention a car race that is controlled by
a eyes versus human drivers is gonna
look completely different than any other
street race you've seen watching it just
start flying I'm like like really
putting a lot of faith in the software
okay I think it's taking a picture
yeah see how it's freezing everything I
think it's working
remember how Nikko had me spend three
weeks doing this last year and we never
talked about it in a vlog and we still
refused to so this could be a really
difficult video to do because the
intensity of these VFX shots it's far
greater than any other video we've done
guys I made my first crappy 3d model
it's really crappy but I made it well
the concept works the drone it flies
itself the program it puts the pictures
together by itself that's two jobs down
the only issue right now is that the
model I made sucks and the goal is to
make a shot that doesn't suck so I need
a good car model a good animation I need
a good photo scan to work with and then
I need a good render of it all currently
I still don't have any of those things
apparently in popular games like
oblivion and many others you can shoot
an arrow into the air and if you don't
move it'll come back down in the same
spot let's give it a shot I have no idea
what I'm doing here I don't know what
the plan is I don't have a bow some more
bows and arrows in the trunk go go get
it
how's this sorry guys I'm loose
awesome promising idea live like this
close actually how difficult is it to to
do this I mean we've only succeeded once
how many shots have we taken six I think
we should do at least ten just so we
have like a common you know where the
health trim factor he said he was
getting an arrow or a bow or something
[Music]
all right don't look up because you
don't want it to hit you in the head
really no no no we want to stand still
we're trying to hit ourselves on the top
of the head oh boy I don't know that
arrow looked a little sharp no dude
they're all padded yeah not mine is
sharper than that at least you sent a
regular error was there are you the one
in the car I just did you guys guys
arguing over this is not gonna help okay
I think it's pretty clear that Sam is
about to die when that arrow comes back
down yeah so let's just let's same have
a moment to do everything he needs to do
before he goes
hey hun there's an arrow it's rapidly
travelling towards my skull and I think
it's gonna pierce me here's my head and
cause instant death
ya know instant instant I won't feel a
thing I'm gonna call my lawyer too hey
Sam hey Jake
so I guess I'll see you guys later
it's coming out any second now any
second thanks to Skillshare for
sponsoring this video I'll talk about
storyboards I started doing storyboard
like professionally three years ago the
mostly live-action feature films
commercials just telling stories just
like the funnest part for me I started
with like comics serve works very
similar one of the main things I really
enjoy about comics is they're able to
portray like kinetic energy feels really
intense it's really fast just just with
static images I try to use that as much
as I can in store or get Skillshare is
an online learning community more than
15,000 classes and design photos and
more from experts working in their field
I got school share and I found one that
was taught by Leo M he's a story artist
at Disney it's pretty good like takes
you through from the beginning to the
end kind of gives you some theory it's
definitely more for a beginner but you
could take a script I held thumbnail
what he thinks the panels are it's just
something real fast real small just to
get the idea across then that's when you
go to your first draft you have a bigger
size getting more detail more poses the
action is clear the 180 rule a person
was on one side stays on that side to
make it look like the actual character
had some shading Star Wars don't tend to
have color unless they're requested more
in commercials because they want it to
be as close to the finished product as
possible it's a pitch there's always an
emotion you trying to portray in the
scene horror scene action scene try to
use the camera to kind of amplify that
emotion horror you have a lot of up
shots you'll see the difference if you
just try filming something straight
ahead and it's supposed to be scary not
gonna feel that scary doesn't matter how
much audio scary audio or extreme easy
put in there I'm gonna feel scary if
you're able to use lighting camera
angles and emotions so people will feel
it when they watch it they'll instantly
feel it compared to something that's
really flat characters might say
something that will sound scary but if
you could tell a story with the owl
sound or color that's when you're doing
a good job yeah check out leo a.m. on
Skillshare it's a good way to start
the SCOOTER is offering three months for
99 cents in January since our fans are
so special either extending that offer
to February 15 so click the link below
to start doing Starbucks check it out
there comes a time in the life of every
desk where it's run its course
[Music]
stop it I know you like your setup and
office is working kind of a brand new
feel pretty looking desk clean this up a
little bit there's not much room for my
feet you're gonna live a bit I have to
rebuild a charging station
Carmichael is working off of a door that
was first created in 2008 I mr. Sam
Gorski
when he found some doors in the loading
dock and didn't have any money and
turned one of them into a desk
h-how'd it's time to get a new one
you feel sad right now I don't feel sad
actually
no I mean I enjoyed the desk I really
did pretty pretty but now if I'm gonna
get a brand new desk
I think my goal will be to make the most
efficient clean organized desk system
for the stamina co-channel no even under
the desk it will be neatly organized no
cheating
so you're gonna have like a computer
that's sitting the right way enough Jake
wants me to get rid of it but I refuse
I don't cuz I love this desk I am one
with this desk I do not want to leave
this desk and Porter is desk they can do
whatever they want with it
but that's that's not a response it's a
fix college door it still has all like
do you member the movie Blood Dragon and
buy movie I mean the YouTube video a VHS
tape that flew through the air near the
beginning and I had the Omega symbol on
the Greek letter we still have the
etching marks from when we cut it out of
the silver reflective material this was
like Sam's desk back when in like 2010
when they had like zero subscribers I
don't want you to lose that history if
it's part of your what makes you what
makes you burn creatively what I think
we should do it can be scared I'm mad
I'm apprehensive this isn't like a
really this this isn't actually like a
you know it's rickety it's a freaking
c-clamp yeah I mean you have this
available is this this door now this is
a solid piece of wood what we should do
we should cut this and use it make size
hide the cables and you get a better
desk that's the same desk that's what
I'm suggesting
then here's the main thing reason why I
don't like these desks here is because
of the cable management I don't like the
little holes I like having the cables
just Free Willy
we got a compromise here somewhere
what are you doing what are you doing
you just got any dust I've realized my
computer would have better ventilation
but leave it right over here rather than
under my desk I want to have a clean
desk and make a great organization to do
so I mean you drill hole
[Laughter]
[Music]
the desks are now complete you also
might notice that we got a new camera
for the salmon eco channel my tusks
right here right what would you say what
kind of wood is this some rich in some
rich cherry wood desk nick has the same
no longer do I have a door and Nick no
longer has just a random table you know
you'll notice this thing right here this
little platform also made out of
beautiful cherry wood it's on top of
both of our desks something that Nick
and I really wanted last year that we
haven't been able to do for a while is
stand while editing both sides and we
just lift it up squeeze lower grab the
chair we have options that's what
matters so what do you think about
standing in it really nice to just be
able to kind of like dance around
up here it's all work but down here
party town no it's the difference
between being in a cage and being free
the difference between a dirty ancient
coin and a clean ancient coin it's the
difference between North Korea and South
Korea now we just need to work on our
cable management we gotta order some
parts but until then vlog team deploy
the way that the guys want to go about
doing this is with photo scanned
environments and CG cars like oh yeah
we'll just make some CG cars well throw
in a photo scanned environment and do
all these crazy camera angles I'm like
yeah who's gonna do that like you are
like oh yeah I don't care that you don't
have any of these abilities you'll learn
it and you'll have to do it in three
weeks it's super janky what do you use
jakey shouldn't be because it's downtown
LA we're trying to scan tons of bits and
you know we agreed no trees so a good
solution of that is to do it in downtown
somewhere or a city
remember when Chad flew his racing drone
with the motorcycles like and was
following those cars like those areas
bushes and stuff and they'll just look
like cotton balls
well not moving at 200 miles an hour man
they're just gonna be like so much photo
scanning if we're going that fast the
whole first week was Rd before we can
actually do this video we need to know
whether or not we can do this video like
from a technological standpoint 3d
models of cars easy
they're everywhere online you can get
them for free or really cheap rendering
them pretty easy the environment was the
problem in movies and stuff the 3d
environments they have in movies are
actually like really high quality cuz
they spend a lot of time and a lot of
money to make sure that they look real
and they look great we don't have that
time or money to be able to do that sort
of stuff so we're just kind of hopefully
there a little bit of janking to the
picture and just photoscan something and
hopefully that'll be enough here's a
hundred strip piece of road here let's
just get all of this photo scanned and
then we'll process that that'll be like
our 3d model of that 100 foot street and
we basically just duplicate that you
know a dozen times to get this really
long straightaway or it's two cars going
200 miles an hour down a 45
incline like like how funny would that
be though funny isn't the word I would
use to describe what I'm seeing in my
head
incredible is that closer I am not
confident it'll be enough Sam trying to
take care of the photo scanning
environments and stuff I was trying to
take care of some sort of system to
animate a car along the road so we
decided to go with mad car which is a
plug-in that works inside of 3ds max
what is it it's a car simulator take a
car and it doesn't matter whether it's
like a fully modeled car or literally
just a toy car just tell the program ok
here's the car body these are the wheels
and then you create like a suspension
system to attach the wheels to the body
and then you simulate it and it takes
into account the ground plane and the
car lands on the ground and then you can
actually drive it like you would a video
game how far can we push this what we
want the whole point of all this R&D is
so that we can get one single shot so we
can do that one shot up to the level
that we want
we'll be like ok we can do this at scale